[Music]
[Applause]
always great to see Brady Quinn Brady
part of the big noon kickoff crew they
were in Happy Valley on Saturday for
Michigan's win and the former NFL
quarterback joining us on the program
what did you expect to happen like
Friday when you're in Happy Valley and
Michigan's coming in did you think Jim
Harbaugh was coaching on
Saturday uh well initially when I woke
up I did until Tony patiti the Big 10
commissioner had suspended him for the
rest of the regular season and and then
we kind of got word that Michigan
understood this was going to happen and
because of that uh they were going to
fire file a trro and try to create an
injunction which I'm no legal expert so
I'm not going to dive into that but just
from being a player uh during the
lockout back after what 2010 2011 I I
knew enough to know that like well this
is a holiday weekend we're uh we're
supporting our veterans on honoring our
veterans uh and and typically um you
know courts don't don't rule very fast
on this so if they think they're going
to be able to get an injunction it's
probably not gonna happen in time for
this game uh maybe sometime next week
but uh I think the crazy thing DP was
I've never gone into like a studio show
and you could probably uh you know admit
to this too like 80 90% of what you
prepare for probably goes into the show
when we got up Saturday morning we had
to prepare for like so many different
scenarios I mean we were honestly
waiting for like Harbo just to walk out
onto the field and and the athletic
director at Penn State Pat craft said he
wasn't going to get in the way of it and
and we were like fully prepared for like
what's gonna happen in that moment like
do we have a live camera on his hotel
room like as he walks out and gets into
the car to drive to the stadium there
and everyone's booing him he's looking
like the villain like I was picturing a
WWE type entrance there in Happy Valley
it unfortunately didn't happen but that
was some of the the greatest drama I've
ever seen when it comes to a college
football game at least the preparation
for it let's look at the big 10 side of
this what exactly are they doing what do
they have to do what do they you know
because you got to say to everybody else
in the Big 10 nobody's above you know
the rules and everything but uh help us
understand what you think the Big 10 is
hoping to accomplish here I think
they're trying to appease every other
big 10 School their coach their athletic
directors and presidents who are looking
at this situation saying the NCA clear
must have enough evidence to be able to
look at Michigan and and claim that
they've broken a rule for sportsmanship
and they should be able to be punished
but we don't want to have to wait until
after the season for that to be the case
and where Jim Harbaugh who knows what
could happen he could go on to the NFL
and this team could go on and win a
National Championship and they feel like
they probably need to you know listen to
the the rest of the Big 10 coaches out
there they feel like hey this has been
going on for a while we feel like you
know they're in the wrong here and this
needs to stop the tough thing is is it's
a precedent that Tony petiti is going to
be setting down in his first year and I
think the thing where my mind wanders to
is when I got drafted in the NFL in 2007
you know Roger Goodell took over as NFL
commissioner and there always existed
this player conduct policy within the
collective bargaining agreement but no
one had really enforced it the way Roger
Goodell did and I think as he enforced
the player conduct policy there are some
unforeseen situations that came up that
he was then going to be on the hook for
and having to make decisions on and how
he's going to punish players and and and
how one player would be compared to
another and I almost wonder if that's
where the Big 10 or in this case Tony
petiti is going with this where he's
going to open up a bunch of other
potential issues where if anything
happens to a big 10 team you know do
they have the investigative armed to be
able to look through this and come up
with a decision that's not going to
somehow end up in the courts um and I
think the other thing is it sounds like
at least from what the big 10 stated
everything that they're basing their
decision to suspend Jim Harbaugh off of
was all based on an CA investigation uh
which is unprecedented so I kind of look
at this and and wonder where where it
stops for Tony patiti moving forward
based on the punishment not just for a
head coach but the players involved too
and and also it sounded like from their
words they're punishing Jim harbach as
he's the figurehead but they don't
necessarily have any direct ties to him
yet outside of he was the head coach
there so it it seems like there's still
a lot to sort out over the course of the
next few weeks maybe even months until
we know everything but it feels like
also it could be open up Pandora's box
for Tony PTI moving forward yeah I kept
saying due process just if they're
guilty they're guilty but now as we keep
going on and maybe this is you know
moved to the end of the
postseason is there a chance Michigan
has to Forfeit wins if if you're guilty
of cheat like what is cheating and what
do you you know what do you lose if if
that's going to harball might be
suspended for the rest of the regular
season but could they be throwing away a
couple of Seasons here full of you know
these Victory totals
possibly I mean who knows I mean we've
seen the punishment the NCA has handed
out before it's always kind of like
retroactive they vacate WIS and take
away postseason and ends up hurting the
current players not the past players or
coaches who was a part of whatever was
going on so it doesn't really seem just
in in my mind at least I think the
interesting thing you bring up though is
like how far does this go as far as
providing michig an advantage and I'm
sure that opinion varies depending on
the coach you talk to you know there's
some coaches who don't think it you know
it helps them quite as much there's some
who think it's a huge Advantage I mean
if you think about like the information
they're Gathering the data it's it's all
you know going to be applied to
hopefully the right situations once you
get into the game and you're hoping that
if Michigan's scouting everyone out that
everyone's using the same signals same
calls I mean nowadays it feels like
everyone's got sence Steelers that are
on Sidelines trying to figure that out
in game who knows if there's other
schools doing this and they just haven't
been caught for doing this so there's
just a lot of questions as to the
advantage that this actually gives
Michigan and I think from a former
player what bothers me about it is it
almost takes away from the success this
team's had the past couple of years on
the field I mean this team has been
dominant on the like I'll put it this
way this past week they didn't need to
steal any signs in fact they didn't need
to throw the football in the second half
first Penn State they ran the ball 32
straight times they had one pass attempt
that end up getting wiped out for DPI
and they still beat Penn State in happy
Val but why do it though Brady why why
do you have somebody who is decoding
this if it doesn't help that's the hard
I I I think I mean who knows again how
long this has been going on there's
pictures of Conor stallions on the
sidelines of Michigan that predates when
a lot of these allegations have been
brought up so we I don't know I mean if
you're only saying hey he's only been
there the past two years that's not the
truth he's been there before that and so
was it helping them when they weren't
winning the Big 10 and they weren't
having as great of an advantage um
there's just there's still so many
questions I think the reason why you do
it is because like anyone else you're
always trying to find an edge and they
probably thought this was something that
you know wasn't over the bounds or if it
was against the rules maybe it was a
rogue actor in this case there's there's
still so much we don't know in in this
case so I don't want to speculate on all
of it but I would say this I feel for
the current players that are there I
think they've responded in a manner
where they're like you think you think
we're stealing signs like we'll show you
like we'll show you just how good we are
Conor St isn't here anymore our head
coaches has been suspended earlier this
year he wasn't here for this game we'll
just keep winning football games and
moving forward so that's where my
thought goes is I'm just more concerned
about the players that are involved in
all this and how it impacts them moving
forward talking to Brady Quinn he was uh
at Penn State for Michigan's win I guess
you guys are uh groupies for Michigan
you're just going to follow them that's
that's your band Michigan is going to
play Maryland so you guys are on the
road with Michigan again yeah I mean it
kind of worked out where we had that
game anyway which has typically been our
model moving forward and obviously we
have Ohio State Michigan which we were
going to be at you know probably
regardless of whether we had that game
but we're fortunate enough to have it
every year so it made a lot of sense
coming off the story based on what we're
anticipating happening uh with hor ball
maybe even being back coaching next week
for the next two weeks of the regular
season depending on the injunction so it
just kind of followed suit with our uh
you know with what we were doing so
again hopefully we get that live camera
on Jim Harbaugh like that's I've pitched
that DP and I'm not even lying to you
I've told our producer Bia I was like
man we need to get his hotel a live
camera like if we can get a shot of him
just like kick back you know legs up
just watching the game or maybe he's up
pacing like who knows that would be
great live TV like a live camera on Jim
Harbaugh then also a second box you know
two box with with the game going on as
well I agree we brought it up over the
weekend we would love to have instead of
the game I wanted to watch Harbaugh
watch the game I thought that would that
would have been great um let me ask you
about CJ Stout and you know the kind of
the pre-draft information smear
campaigns that happened because I
remember when CJ strad was coming out
and the knock was could he process the
information at the line of scrimmage and
I think there was something a cognitive
test and he didn't do well and that got
leaked here how much of that is happens
even now that a team may want CJ stoud
but then they have to pollute the waters
to make sure you don't take CJ Stroud
yeah a team may do it an agent may do it
I think the agents are a lot more in
that process too of leaking out
information like that than than even the
teams in that case so everyone's trying
to throw out smoke screens and posture I
mean that was the thing that never
really made sense about that and I've
never taken that cognitive test I'm I'm
not sure how effective it is I know
there's a lot of people who really
believe in it or portions of it but when
you watch the tape you never saw that
and that that was where one where you
know maybe if you get a test like that
you go back and watch it and it either
confirms it or it doesn't but I've
always been a big advocate of saying
like what does the tape tell you and the
things about CJ Stroud's game which made
him the number two overall pick and made
him potentially looking back on it where
we should have looked at him and said he
should have been the number one overall
pick is his accuracy and playing from
the pocket like he was so accurate and
lethal downfield throwing the football
and that that's what wins like as much
as we get enamored with players who can
extend plays and create off you know
script plays because those are the
splash wild plays that's still not
always what wins Super Bowls I mean Tom
Brady is the best case of that obviously
the greatest of all time in my opinion
and and he played from the pocket from
the pocket now momes has the ability to
create and he's obviously trying to
chase down Tom Brady now so we'll we'll
see where that goes but that was one of
those things that when you w looked at
CJ Stroud's game you could have made the
case he was the most NFL prepared from
that perspective of any of the
quarterbacks who were up in last year's
draft you just you really didn't have
any concerns outside of like some of the
smoke screens and stuff that people
would throw out there yeah I just
watched the Georgia game and I go he can
play I mean he's great and and he's
showing that is Texas A&M a big-time
program
I I I think it is I think when you've
got the money to buy out a coach for
almost 77 million I I think you have to
look at it as one or one that could even
pay a coach that uh they've obviously
recruited at a really high level and
they've got a story tradition and
history it's just we haven't seen the
results um we've seen flashes of it but
we we haven't seen really the results
that I think their fan base thinks they
should be getting and and and quite
honestly probably what the AP poll uh is
most responsible for and that's the fact
that if you look at the last three
seasons they've started the preseason
ranked top 25 maybe top 20 top 15 and
then as The Season's worn on they've you
know faded away to the point where
they've been unranked and I I think
that's a a byproduct of the fact that we
have these preseason rankings that are
based on what I mean I'm I know why we
do them like you have to do them it's
part tradition but part like you're
selling the games there's so many teams
it's like well if it's if they don't
have a number next to them like God is
anyone going to watch it's like well
yeah they're still going to watch but
maybe it doesn't feel as important can't
sell it uh I've always been a big
advocate of just saying like the AP poll
doesn't even matter anymore like this is
now about the college football playoff
committee yeah so why have rankings
until then you just see the record well
sometimes we'll look at a team and we'll
go God what's wrong with them well
what's wrong with them is they were
ranked too high to begin with or
somebody was ranked too low and they're
like wow nobody saw this one coming yeah
and and most of those rankings are based
on like hey maybe how they finished the
year before how many guys they have
coming back uh what's the recruiting
rankings we typically look at recruiting
classes and go oh well they're a top 10
class they've got to be able to win a
bunch of football games right they have
talent and when it's not an exact
science measuring how a kids gonna trans
transition from high school to college
football and I think we've seen evidence
of that specifically with Texas ANM and
how a lot of that star studed Class A
few years ago really transitioned into
college station and there was some
locker room issues cultural issues and
and look Jimbo Fischer's got to be
responsible for that I think that's what
you saw Florida State towards the end of
his tenure like that kind of falling
apart and I think that's what what's
happened here I mean he constructed a
good staff but they just couldn't figure
out a way of winning and I think the
last thing I'll just point to is
quarterback development and having a guy
that can play you know you had jamus
Winston he won a Heisman he helped win a
National Championship and go to the
college football playoff I don't know
that jimo fisher was able to kind of
find that guy to help carry them at
Texas ANM or develop that guy to become
that outside of Kell M which I think you
know had their best year in that Co year
which was kind of a hit or miss year for
a lot of teams did we send you a t-shirt
we we made up a t-shirt the Will Ferrell
yelling at you from the sidelines hey 10
your pants are too high um I thought
it'd be like a beefo Brady t-shirt at
this point Paulie's going out to get it
are you uh a double
XL I I mean I would like to think I'm a
quadruple XL but I'm probably not like
an XL now honestly an XL yeah I'm a guy
who's wearing golf shirts now DP it's
it's not it's not fun getting old what
happened to you I I don't I can't hit
the ball as far off the tea I I tried
powerlifting and I like hurt my back
half the time so here's the uh t-shirt
that's awesome that's awesome thank you
did you get will one too though did he
get one as well oh yeah yeah we we made
up a few of these so if you would like
uh a t-shirt you know we be more than
happy to send you a couple you know what
you have all your daughters you know
maybe we could send it for the entire
family you'd have to explain to them
exactly what it means but will Ferell
yelling at you from the sidelines at USC
Notre Dame making fun of you look if
you're going to be famous for one thing
like I'll take that like I I'd love to
be famous for will frell heckling me on
the sidelines on my pants for too high
yeah uh great to talk to you thanks for
joining us and uh we'll talk to you soon
all right thanks for having me that's
Brady Quinn they'll be uh in College
Park it's Michigan and
Maryland uh the uh big noon kickoff crew
two Pros in a cup of joe the show that
precedes ours on Fox Sports Radio